Fox news's Sean Hannity thought that he
would bring on Democratic California
governor Gavin Newsom and make him look
dumb by getting him to talk about Biden
and getting him to talk about California
and Gavin Newsom proved everything I
have been saying about him for the last
several months you know Gavin Newsom is
not the most Progressive but Gavin
Newsom strikes exactly the right tone
demeanor and temperament that the
Democratic party could use more of this
is a guy who every time I see him
interviewed proves that he is a serious
potential future Contender for the
Democratic presidential nomination now
would he be attacked for being the
liberal California
yeah he would uh would he have answers
to those claims he would look at this
interview and look at how Newsome
crushes Sean Hannity on his own show
starting here with economic issues this
is a clinic this when you have trainings
done of democratic candidates this is
what you need to be showing for our
president I have great confidence in his
I don't know
accomplish I think his policies are
failing ah chip sack science act you
oppose that I will tell you on every
measure from the economy inflation
borders energy uh National Security he's
missing in action let's talk about them
in order wait but I want to challenge
the premise Kennedy wants to list them
but he doesn't want to go through one by
one typical the economy 13.1 million
jobs he's created more these opposed
Cova jobs you know that I mean that's an
artificial number then let me just let
me circulate this as an as an
opportunity to engage civilly on this
okay Fair Point your president Donald
Trump lost 2.6 million jobs during his
four years we've created 13.1 million
fine you can maintain a covet frame how
about the fact that Joe Biden's created
more jobs six times more jobs than the
previous three Republican presidents
you're buying are you going to tell me
that the average family where we have
two-thirds of Americans now living
paycheck to paycheck it was 70 under
Trump that's just freaking brilliant
guys guys that this is exact they love
to cite these numbers two-thirds of
families are now paycheck to paycheck of
course it's not actually two-thirds
two-thirds would be 66.6 percent the
number is actually in the low 60s so
Hannity rounds up and Newsome points out
that number is down like seven points
from when Trump was President this is
exactly how you have to fight these guys
we have the lowest unemployment rate for
every demographic and they are even
lower now we have the lowest rate and
you and I are living with the lowest
unemployment we have in our lifetime
every demographic and the economy black
unemployment's record low under Joe
Biden okay we had historic low after
historic low under Donald Trump and it
is even better now this is how you don't
back down from these bullies two of the
best messaging folks I'm talking from a
communication standpoint right now okay
we're not doing a policy analysis are on
the left are Gavin Newsom and Pete boot
Edge okay this is how you have to fight
these people now obviously this alone
won't win you elections I'm not
delusional but this is how you do it
here is the topic of inflation and
Newsome is just barreling through
Hannity question I'm answering the ones
in order brought up the economy on the
economy let's talk about the economy
inflation stubborn around the globe
let's let's but let's talk about
inflation it's down 40 since last summer
10 months in a row 4.9 percent he was
just and by the way now down to four
percent this interview was from last
night so that's why they don't have that
data yet UK prime minister it's 6.9 is
that because of Biden's I think violence
economic and energy policies directly
impacted the UK's inflation no the fact
that France is 5.5 or Germany's at six
years on inflation we're moving in the
right direction folks he's steamrolling
him this it it's stunning Hannity is
Hannity is lost control
and he doesn't have the facts on his
hand on the issue of the border security
inherited 1.4 inflation it went up to a
40-year highly 40-year High globally
globally because you've just brought
that so you were making an excuse for
Trump's dismal jobs record ready to
covered's relationship to inflation this
is folks this is this is textbook
Hannity wants to have it both ways yes
Trump lost 2.6 million jobs but that was
because of covid but what about high
inflation under Biden well hold on
that's globally because of covid oh no
then it's not then covet isn't the
explanation Newsome is almost perfect on
this Hannity pulls the Biden's weak
thing here is Newsom I think he's a man
of decency and character I'm really
proud of the president proud of what
he's accomplished he's strong enough to
be president that's I'm strong enough
but he just did to McCarthy he ran look
at the vote card
exactly Kevin got played by the
president United States I'm for results
did you did you see what just happened
did you see that Hannity is agreeing
with Newsom newsom's making the argument
if Biden is so weak how did he have
McCarthy wrapped around his finger and
got McCarthy to do exactly what he
wanted and Hannity goes I wouldn't vote
have voted for that bill that McCarthy
voted for that's the point if Biden is
so weak how did he perfectly engineer
McCarthy into doing what he wanted him
to do here just a couple more of these
and this we could do this all day here's
Newsom explaining hey you know
California actually works pretty well
yeah things are expensive because people
want to go there it's called supply and
demand but California is working for
pretty damn well in 2021 California 7.8
percent of GDP GDP growth in this
country one of the fastest growing
economies anywhere on planet Earth this
state continues to be the Temple of the
American economy 25.6 of All American
jobs came from this state in April and
the last two fiscal years we enjoyed
177.7 billion dollars in operating
surpluses we're on our way to be the
fourth largest economy Eat Your Heart
Out Germany in the world number one in r
d Venture Capital more scientists
researchers more Nobel laureates more
patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America with all due
respect Florida doesn't even come close
eat your heart out of Texas California
continues to be appreciate dominant
economic engine for them I promised you
before this interview I would let you
give full answers that's a full answer
thank you yeah it is and yeah I mean
when you can't when you can't argue the
facts Hannity has no choice but to say
thank you for at least answering the
questions and here lastly is um uh he
knew some just humiliating Ron DeSantis
they were told they had jobs they told
they were going to get certain court
dates changed they were dropped off they
knocked on the door and they left and
there was not coordinated I mean what
kind of Faith tradition everything else
there was a video of humanization of the
people getting on the because they were
all lied to and told and they were being
taken care of everything's going to be
great I would be proud and happy then
then because by the way I have the RFP
because they landed in your Sanctuary
State you're going to take care of them
they should be happy look we'll we'll
deal with the car come on this is
California I know it's called okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course you
have this okay I'm a border state Rhonda
Santos is not I know he's desperate to
get into the ACT no because a lot of
people Donald Trump is going to clean is
it there's a Joe Biden
and he set this up months ago by doing
an RFP I have the contractor okay my
question he tried to hire saying he was
going to send people to California this
is a stunt it's embarrassing it's not
pathetic I I did not I think he did the
right thing his State's not a sanctuary
she did the right thing by by flying
migrants around even though I can't
explain why folks this is a formidable
political force and this is not about
cheerleading Newsome as the epitome of
the progressive candidate this is about
a model for the Next Generation
Democratic movement that better knows
how to deal with these would-be bullies
if you didn't know any better you'd
think that was Gavin newsom's show and
that he was allowing Hannity to say a
few things things which by the way
didn't make a lot of sense
excellent job by Gavin Newsom
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description